[Music]
the sound of a mother's love
echoing through the Malaysian jungle the
hope is that may've cuarón's daughter
will hear her calls and if she can walk
towards them
this elite commando force has now joined
a team of over 250 people on a sixth day
of searching for fifteen-year-old Nora
disabilities ship's been using drones
helicopters and sniffer dogs as well as
handing out fliers to local residents
with noise photograph on them police say
she may have climbed out of this window
in her family's holiday home found open
after her disappearance it's not from
inside but her family say she'd never
leave them voluntarily Nora likes to
walk with her family but her balance is
limited and she struggles with
coordination she has been to Asia before
and she's been to many European
countries and she's never wandered off
or got lost Nora is very sensitive I
tried the family door is very shy it
could be quite anxious and every night
she has special time for cuddles and a
nighttime story with her mom and she was
just extremely excited about spending
time with her family on a holiday in
Tunisia the authorities are once again
searching the resort where Nora
disappeared set in an orchard right next
to the vast expanse of jungle focusing
getting any information which can we go
back to the place and pinpoint the exact
spot any of the SX but around including
the building's the Shelly around to
recheck again as they step up their team
search authorities fear that Nora
wouldn't easily negotiate the dense
woods of this nature reserve alone but
alongside her family and all the locals
here they're praying for a miracle your
Mashhad x KY news